for you like staying independent how
important is that because i mean i'm
sure
at any given time there's been
opportunities to go to a major to you
know it's it's big to stay independent
man i just feel like independent that
way
to go not saying that i i'm putting like
this too
i'm somebody who really cared for
nothing
you know what i'm saying so
they come my way with like some life
changing [ __ ] like
something you doing there k refused
right
i damn there feel like i'd be dumb not
to right
but
besides that i'm i'm steering away with
the
problem is a lot of times these labels
will come through and they'll offer you
an advance for a shitty deal and i'm
like yeah i already got that in the bank
i'm doing that right now
what am i supposed to do with this it
really got to make sense like you gotta
because i'm like we really doing numbers
right
independent upcoming artists i mean your
jewelry would say you're not independent
because that is a massive uh
well i appreciate it it's a lot of hard
work man that's all it is